ja und dieser mann der sitzt auf gras im
wert von 30 millionen euro und sein
geschäft könnte schon bald explodieren
denn in stefan lange als ehemaligem nato
spionage bunker mitten im bayerischen
allgäu da lagern drei tonnen cannabis
das ist eu rekord bisher hat der
besitzer der firma avery avid apotheken
mit medizinischen cannabis versorgt die
ampel regierung könnte ihn jetzt aber
zum cannabis könig von europa krönen
denn kabel ist könnte schon im herbst
nächsten jahres legal seien dann sitzt
stefan lange auf unfassbar viel geld und
das grüne gold muss auch gut bewacht
sein
der bunker den wir hier sehen und in dem
das cannabis lagert hat ein meter 35
meter dicken stahlbetonwände 32 dicke
decken sobald die kontrollierte abgabe
an erwachsene kommt muss stefan langer
nur noch den knopf drücken sein
unternehmen hat alle lizenzen dass
cannabis und die notwendigen maschinen
deutschlands cannabis königs sitzt auf
heißen kohlen im wahrsten sinne des
wortes alle zeichen stehen auf expansion
und wir sind jetzt mit ihm verbundene
live hier bei uns in der sendung
sogar zu zweit hallo ich sollte es
gefunden
da kann man ja schon gratulieren wie
haben sie dieses geschäft aufgebaut und
wie heißen sie darauf dass es jetzt
endlich losgeht
waren ja sehr viele superlative in ihrem
vortrag drin dank dafür
wir haben vor vier jahren angefangen es
war klar dass nach dem medizin gesetz
wird weitergehen in der kontrollierte
abgabe bis hin zu einem recreational
markt wir haben von vornherein auf eine
vollautomatische verarbeitung gesetzt
von vollautomatischen erp system über
vollautomatische verpackung straße
wir freuen uns jetzt auf die
kontrollierte abgabe an erwachsene wenn
sie denn kommt und wann sie kommt ist
man ja noch nicht bis jetzt
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich gar nicht genau
wer gerade neben steht vielleicht
stellen sich selbst kurz vor
ja ich gebe mir das mikrofon weiter das
ist unsere geschäftsführer dr david zu
you hallo david zurück freut mich freut
uns auch wir machen uns natürlich bei
aller freude über ihr geschäft auch
sorgen ob das ganze denn so die richtige
entscheidung ist jetzt bin ich gespannt
was sie sagen ja nichts mehr
bei david war leider der ton weg ich
versuche es zu erklären obwohl
eigentlich die antwort von david
wesentlich besser werden
man muss natürlich schon schauen also
cannabis ist ein genussmittel genauso
wie alkohol und tabak und man stelle
sich vor wir dürften jetzt alkohol und
tabak neu regulieren dass wir auch eine
chance bei cannabis es ist ein stoff der
wesentlich ungefährlicher ist als die
anderen beiden genussmittel hat aber
auch seine tücken von daher ist es schon
wichtig von vornherein mit augenmaß die
gesetze so zu wählen dass man weiter mit
statistiken erst mal eben kann und dann
weitere entscheidungen trifft was sagen
sie denen die jetzt sagen ja gut mein
sohn meine tochter ist abhängig von
cannabis ist es drogensüchtig
ich denke da muss ein bisschen
differenzieren wenn wir im moment die
situation dass der überwiegende material
auf dem schwarzmarkt gekauft wird unter
unkontrollierten bedingungen reden wir
nicht von einem reinen cannabis produkt
sondern wir reden davon dass er zum teil
cannabinoide und andere chemikalien
künstlicher art darauf gesprüht werden
sodass wir nebenwirkungsprofil haben die
nicht vergleichbar sind mit medizinal
cannabis und natürlich gibt es auch bei
medizinal cannabis die frage der sucht
situation aber die gilt ja auch für
alkohol und zigaretten und dann müssen
wir eben durch die zukünftigen
gesetzlichen regelungen wege und mittel
finden um eine kontrollierte abgabe
sicherzustellen um sowas zu vermeiden
nun lagern bei ihnen drei tonnen glaube
ich haben wir gesagt cannabis wo haben
sie das überhaupt
im hinterkopf auch dass angebote
beispielsweise der neuen taliban
regierung in afghanistan
die deutschland gerne mit gras versorgen
will
vor dem angebot haben auch gehört habe
es natürlich auch mit einem schmunzeln
wahrgenommen wir beziehen unser cannabis
aus kanada und portugal
mit unsere lizenzen dürften wir aus der
ganzen welt importieren so lange dass
cannabis in dem entsprechenden
spezifikationen ist bei dem taliban
cannabis ist auf alle fälle interessant
opium produzieren sie ja auch ich bin
jetzt nicht sicher wir haben opium
pflaster auf dem markt werden die auch
in der opel-fabrik in afghanistan
produziert weil die sind ja der größte
opium prozent wenn sie das machen
brauche ich dann eben auch gern cannabis
fabrik auf aber vorher glaube ich ist
eine tolle idee aber wird wahrscheinlich
nicht umsetzbar seien das heißt sie
würden aber mit den taliban geschäfte
machen ganz möglich wäre
afghanistan ist nicht nur taliban und
jetzt haben wir nach 20 jahren alles
mögliche versucht das nicht funktioniert
hat wir sollten vielleicht erst mal
andere wege suchen und den
wirtschaftskraft bieten und eine
alternative ist vielleicht auch nicht
das schlechteste mit dem taliban muss
man sich jetzt arrangieren
aber das sind themen die kindgerecht
wenig an ich kenne mich mit cannabis aus
weniger mit politik tut mir leid jetzt
haben sie ja hier wir sehen auch die
bilder die ganze zeit eine nato bunker
also ein hochsicherheitstrakt warum und
gab es bei ihnen schon in irgendeiner
form einbruchsversuche
nein also es hat noch keiner versucht
und ich gehe auch schwerer von hassels
wird keiner probieren dafür schreckt das
gebäude schon zu sehr ab
wir haben natürlich schauen müssen wie
können wir in den vorgaben der
bundesopiumstelle bleiben und trotzdem
noch kostengünstigen einfachen betrieb
aufbauen die sicherungsmaßnahmen für
cannabis sind recht umfangreich
man braucht
mindestens 45 zentimeter dicke wände da
findet man kein gebäude der außerdem
bunkert dass wir diesen nato bunker der
stillgelegtes gefunden haben und die
gemeinden eigentlich auch ein gutes
konzept gewartet haben und dann auch
noch positiv gestimmt waren gegenüber
cannabis war natürlich für unseren
glücksfall einbrechen wird bei uns hier
keiner selbst selbst spezialkräfte
würden wir wahrscheinlich wochen
brauchen bis sie durch die ersten beiden
türen sind brauchen sie beide selbst
auch mal einen joint
ich spreche da wird mit nein da wird gar
nicht ich selber bin patient also ich
hab zwei sachen ich habe ein glaukom und
adhs
wenn ich jetzt nicht kann das rauchen
wird es gibt natürlich verschiedene
sorten ich auch untertags eine die mir
focus gibt mich mich bisserl ruhiger
macht ansonsten wäre ich viel zu
hibbelig doch meine adhs und abends
ruhig dann der sorte die mich eher
ins bett bringt weil ansonsten nicht
zwar müde aber mein kopf ist weiter auf
der autobahn und philosophiert vom naja
ich bin selber konsument deswegen kenne
mich mit dem cannabis aus da wird können
sich über mich aus
irgendeiner von konkurrenzunternehmen
oder wollen sie jetzt die
monopolstellung
also bei uns geht es nicht darum dass
wir selber irgendwie in monopolstellung
wollen ganz im gegenteil wir sehen auch
keine konkurrenten sondern sondern wir
sehen uns als service und abwicklungs
maschine für den gesamten markt wir
haben eigentlich eher kollegen und
freunde und arbeiten wir haben zusammen
wir können hier service leisten von
import über über die ganze welt über
sämtliche dienstleistungen bis hin zur
zur medizinischen marktfreigabe durch
unsere kopie
wir sehen uns eher als als dienstleister
der branche
wie muss man sich das vorstellen wie
wird das dann in zukunft ablaufen wird
es hier so coffee shops geben wie
beispielsweise in den niederlanden also
cafés in dem man das kaufen kann oder
wird man sich sein joint in der apotheke
besorgen können wie soll der vertrieb da
aussehen
ist natürlich auch ein blick in die
glaskugel man kann sich vielleicht ein
paar sachen herleiten da wo man cannabis
kaufen darf wird man es nicht
konsumieren dürfen also damit schon mal
klar wir werden keinen coffeeshop wie in
holland an das zweite ist klar ist
cannabis wird nie mehr
unverpackt verkauft werden es wird
definitiv ein werbeverbot erfolgen
ähnlich wie bei tabak und bei alkohol
auch müssen das heißt eine eigene
verpackung ist die einzige möglichkeit
der selbstdarstellung plus nur so kann
ich gewährleisten dass die
qualitätsstandards hoch bleiben
jetzt kommt natürlich viel viel
meinungen oder oder viel raten dazu ich
gehe davon aus dass es eine
kontrollierte abgabe über apotheken sein
wird war es als medizin gesetz angelehnt
werden kann also es ist eine kleine
erweiterung und die spezifikation für
medizinisches cannabis können übernommen
werden das verhindert wiederum das
schlechte qualität auf dem markt kommt
und dass ich sage jetzt mal unseriöse
mitspieler hier eine schnelle mark
verdienen wollen und das wäre zumindest
mal der sicherste weg alles andere
wird sich zeigen in welche richtung das
sie entwickelt vielen danke stefan
langer der kerner bis könig von
deutschland und seinen geschäftsführer
wir wollen weiter darüber sprechen also
auf der einen seite goldgräberstimmung
quasi in deutschland andererseits
natürlich auch deutliche warnungen vor
drogenmissbrauch versteht die regierung
von olaf scholz plant die kontrollierte
abgabe von gras an volljährige deshalb
haben wir uns in chemnitz mal umgehört
und wollten wissen legal griffen ja oder
nein
das ist nicht nötig weil ja wir haben
medikamente wenn jetzt wirklich
medikamentös behandelt werden soll
ich nutze sicherlich überhaupt nicht
auch eine gewisse freizügigkeit ist
nicht mein enkel oder wahrscheinlich
sorgen ja ich hole sachen
machen das brauchen wir ich bin es nicht
unbedingt notwendig so was zu
legalisieren ja es ist auch mit risiken
verbunden so was gab es noch stehen kann
ist es eine gute sache aber ob das kommt
mal sehen bin ich grundsätzlich dagegen
weil das in der truppe ist meiner
meinung ist muss legt legalisiert werden
so und da bin ich auch ganz dafür und
ich bin auch der meinung die
beschaffungskriminalität wird dadurch
runter gesagt so dass die stadt muss
begreifen so der staat bekommt ja auch
viele steuern dafür ich bin für drogen
er absolut dagegen und sie selber wenn
der beschluss durch schwere was wir
würden sie dann machen
ich würde es nicht weiter tangieren die
frage wäre wie weit man es fiel gegen
schmerzen und ähnliches wird einsetzen
könnte schön was taugen und dann schön
kochen ich bin nämlich gerade der koch
das wäre meiner prognose aber soviel die
jungen leute die das mal abends machen
da ich nie einfach vechta vorwärts auch
nicht werden noch nicht nein